sur la prospective de manière générale
euh depuis ses origines elle a
évidemment évolué dans ses formes ces
principes eux restent relativement
inchangé même si le contexte dans lequel
elle se situe les objets dont elle se
saisit eux euh ont évidemment évolué
relativement de manière relativement
importante sur les principes euh la
définition qui me semble la plus claire
c'est celle affichée ici de Michel godé
qui dit de de quoi s'agit-il quand on
fait la prospective s'agit d'éclairer
l'action présente à la lumière des
futurs possibles et souhaitables
c'est important tout est un peu
important dans cette dans cette
définition l'objectif vous le voyez
c'est pas juste d'être dans le la
futurologie c'est-à-dire d'être en
capacité éventuellement de prédire ce
qui pourrait se passer mais c'est bien
d'éclairer l'action présente de ce point
de vue-là d'ailleurs ça me semble tout à
fait important que la prospective soit
représentée au Sénat puisque un des
objectifs nobles si je puis dire de la
prospective c'est justement aussi de
pouvoir servir à éclairer la décision
publique il s'agit pas de dicter
évidemment la décision publique mais
bien de l'éclairer en portant un regard
sur les enjeux de moyen et de long terme
euh quand on dit porter un regard sur
les enjeux de moyen et de long terme
c'est d'abord un effort tout simplement
c'est-à-dire prendre le temps de se
préoccuper de ces enjeux de moyen et de
long terme alors que l'on sait bien que
dans toutes vos activités dans toutes
nos activités on est très souvent
contraint justement par les urgences du
temps présent donc je dirais de manière
assez simple d'ailleurs que faire de la
prospective c'est d'abord essayer de
sanctuariser en quelque sorte un peu de
temps et un peu de moyens dédiés à cette
réflexion sur le moyen et le long terme